I was born with the devil in me I could
not help the fact that I was a murderer
no more than the poet can help the
inspiration to sing I was born with the
evil ones standing as my sponsor beside
the bed where I was ushered into the
world and he has been with me since
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and we're back for yet another episode
of the 13 o'clock podcast episode 64 is
a matter of fitness sexy coordinate yeah
yeah yeah HH Holmes this is gonna be a
good one and this was actually a request
and I'm apologize that I don't remember
who requested it um I did have it on my
list like for much later but since
someone asked for it a while back I was
like well let's get around to it yeah
and I feel like cuz we did paranormal
last time and I kind of I'm trying to
get into the kind of thing where we're
kind of doing like paranormal true-crime
paranormal that kind of thing I mean you
know no well then we can go back to a
haunting series yeah and stuff like that
but we'll talk about that yeah this is
gonna be a good show I've always liked
this case this is kind of like America's
first big time serial killer yes I've
always kind of had my doubts about it
but Jenny Jenny's dug up some really
good stuff we're gonna discuss yeah I
mean this is a huge huge case and it's
kind of like I almost want to compare it
to like the show remember the show we
did about Elizabeth Bathory
yeah where she was probably a
piece-of-shit person who killed people
but a lot of the stuff like the legends
and stuff thinking about after were
probably not sure wildly exaggerated
and I think that the same thing happened
in the case of HHO yeah but we're gonna
get to that for the London he wasn't a
piece of [ __ ] yeah he was he was a yeah
and he killed people and he did kill
people yeah for those of you who don't
know HH Holmes is just off the top this
is the guy who built basically the
murder cast the murder castle right
right outside the World's Fair in
Chicago in Chicago know what US was was
it late 1800 1800 so yeah late 19th
century around the same time as Jack the
Ripper
they were rough contemporary one of the
unusual things about HH Holmes is that
he was a doctor he actually graduated
medical school which is very unusual for
a serial killer
yeah and they were just always whenever
I'd hear the story is about this guy
there were some always some [ __ ] about
it that didn't really jive with what I
know about serial killers based on my
studies reading the FBI profiler manuals
yeah cuz I read the
books on that yeah you know actually I
read a book by a guy who wrote that book
yeah and serial killers have certain
traits yeah and I never really could
imagine this guy having the traits as
specified he had a different motivation
right normally a serial killer basically
as a serial rapist he just happens to
rape and torture or kill the victim yeah
and there's always something missing
from this case and he never really
struck me as a serial rapist yeah but
we'll get into a second yeah we will
before we do that we just have a couple
of shoutouts first thing I would really
like to give a shout out to our latest
patreon supporter named John thank you
very much for use of one of our youtube
listeners and he also had a couple of
really cool suggestions for topics so I
have so I have put those on the list no
good we will get to those all right
sooner or later but they are on there I
promise
so you know thank you very much for your
support we did a really good cool road
warrior review you guys ought to check
that one out yeah that was our last
movie review and I only just posted
Sunday so because I kind of got behind
speaking of reviews I was I was going
online just looking through old stuff of
ours on Google and everything
somebody reviewed one of our shows it's
a weirdest review ever it was yeah it
was the show we did I can't remember the
episode number it was somewhere in the
40s it was the one we did about Bella in
the which elm and the pitchfork murder
the witchcraft murder and society
somehow related to yeah he was like
related to I think he was related to
Joseph Jacobs who was one of the people
that was questioned in the Belen that
was something or was supposed to be a
Nazi spy or something like that I can't
remember all the details exactly but
this person had it has like a blog where
they talk all about the belen at which
home care and evidently they came across
our episode about it
like he didn't like it didn't really
seem to get the show you guys where they
sure do talk a lot well this is the
[ __ ] talk show you know what would be
funny okay
I'm gonna pull a John Cage you guys and
I'm going to upload a video that's just
an hour of silence yeah you know they
plug their plugging books my god geez we
suck frag out funny man well funny it is
sad yeah oh yeah so
oh also so if so any of you guys would
like to support the show like John has
then you can go to our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or if you'd like to give a
one-time donation you can do that too
and go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's a
little link in the sidebar
that says paypal con donation donate to
paypal or whatever the [ __ ] it says I
don't know yeah and all that kind of
stuff and also like I said my book the
faceless villain is out in print and
eBooks still working on the audio by
security god I'm working on the
audiobook it's just it's just that I get
so much other work that I have to do
because I do this show I do freelance
graphic design I don't know if you guys
know that and all this other stuff so
that stuff usually has priority like cuz
the show has to come out every week and
the movie review has to come out every
week yeah and you know the graphic
design has to get done you know quickly
right it's so funny we first conceived
this show as a way of actually finding
people to give out free samples of
Jenny's books so we can get reviews yeah
but on the books cuz it helps launch a
book but as funny as I'm reading like
some of the reviews on Amazon and we're
finding people who buy the book and by
buying the book they discover the
podcast
yeah they discover the YouTube show you
know I think that's like it's all it's
nice feedback
yeah it's a big feedback loop yeah it's
like it's like a part of the crustle
sphere somehow right we're all part of
the crustle they're all part of the
crustle sphere oh that's what it is it's
beautiful this one hit York Russell like
a halo with his eye patch on no no
gonna have like crunchy from the hateful
eight what is it when he's older what
he's older is lesser with that gang yeah
and then handlebar mustache yeah that
that mustache was pretty opinionated to
say all right so these people there and
let's go ahead and give them this case
well so they have something to do why
they're on their commute to work or you
know they're probably half them are in
bed getting ready trying to go to sleep
Tom and Jenny gonna put them to sleep
with this story that didn't sound good
it's all fun and games yeah okay HH
Holmes this is a weird thing about HH
Holmes and like I said ok we do like a
lot of research on this show like I said
I'm not a super stickler and everything
like that I have red devil in the white
city which is the kind of the most
famous book about him which is sort of
nonfiction but he added some stuff in
there but he said where he added it I
have read the book depraved by Harold
Schechter which is also about him and
but the latest book to come out about HH
Holmes actually only came out in April
of 2017 yeah this is a pretty cool guy
who wrote and it was yes by Adam Selzer
and I admit that I have not read it yet
although I've read a bunch of his blog
posts and I watched some of his lectures
that he gave it on libraries and stuff
like that maybe one day we'll have him
on as a guest he could plug it that'd be
cool cuz he's a historian and he's kind
of he writes about other things too but
he got super fascinated with HH Holmes
case and he discovered that a lot of
this too and I think that this has kind
of been going around for a while in
these circles but a lot of the stuff
that people know of about HH Holmes is
actually not really true or is wildly
exaggerated yeah now you're gonna piss
off a lot of these serial killer fanboys
I'm not well no I mean like I said I'm
not saying he was a killer he did kill
multiple people right and he was a
horrible piece of [ __ ] right but a lot
of the stuff I mean you know I've seen
some stuff that said he killed like 200
people there's no way he did not do that
I don't think he had time I don't think
he did that no it's like I said it's
kind of like he killed a lot of people
but not that many and a lot of this
stuff too that came that was about like
the murder castle also probably not true
yeah we get into pro
with these stories because when you
track them down where these stories come
from they come from old defunct
newspapers and yes it came from a time
when America was basically did nothing
but yellow journalism which may be what
it's what we have now it's not really
that much different yeah
it's they're just trying to sell papers
and sensationalism Venice now sells
papers so if you know if they have to
exaggerate things even if they have to
make things up if it has like a kernel
of truth and then they just like make
all this crazy [ __ ] up then they're
gonna do it because particularly back
then even like one city would have like
a lot of competing newspapers and you
had to kind of get your [ __ ] it's kind
of like the internet now or it's like
we'll just publish anything because we
want to be the first one to get it I'm
trying to get those hits right and stuff
like that so it was the same thing back
then but with newspapers and there were
several more like competing for
attention so they're gonna bring the
most salacious crazy [ __ ] that they can
yeah and I don't think they were liable
laws in the way that we know him now not
so much I mean probably difficult to sue
a newspaper for lying yeah I mean I
think people did but you know it was
probably kind of like you didn't get
much of a didn't get much out of it
maybe not the settlements were probably
pretty small but yeah so okay basically
HH Holmes obviously was not his real
name he was actually born Herman Webster
Mudgett
Henry Holmes is the name he's best known
by dr. Henry Howard Holmes to be more
specific he also had a [ __ ] ton of other
aliases which are much less famous
because first and foremost although
technically he is a serial killer
he was actually a conman first and
foremost yeah it seems that I mean his
big thing was he was a [ __ ]
pathological liar yeah he just really I
don't know what it was about him I mean
like like you said he actually did
finish medical school he was a doctor
like it wasn't just a kind of thing
where he was like saying he was a doctor
a fakir yes he actually did finish
medical and that's the weird thing most
serial killers the kind of path Allah
that they have they don't they can't
gratify RCP they can't delay
gratification right they tend to be
smart enough to get education but they
don't want to wait and go off beyond
work right they don't love yeah this guy
actually went through medical school you
know dealt with cadavers and you know he
actually did it she did a [ __ ] but for
some strange reason instead of trying to
make a living as a doctor which he could
have easily done he was trying to live
as a con man yeah weird
well trying he did he did I guess it was
just easier just easier to be maybe or
maybe it was just easier for his
personality time yeah he seems like a
really weird dude yeah I mean he just
seems like a really weird dude now he
was born actually in 1861 now his
parents were kind of strict Methodists
and stuff like that so later stuff about
him came out that said oh you know his
father was abusive or that Henry Holmes
you know abused animals when he was a
kid and stuff like that you know to try
and fit him into the serial killer the
normal range of serial killer behavior
now it should be that there is no
contemporary evidence to support this no
his father could have been abusive for
all I know but but there is no not
enough evidence there's no evidence to
support that and there's also no
evidence to support that he you know cut
up animals or anything like that now he
did though okay now this is a story that
he tells so I don't know if how hackers
because he made up this - it was very um
self-aggrandizing
yes a that he would climb to kill people
that were never killed they turn to
Dateline because I for some reason I
know it's like twisted but I kind of
find that sort of funny yeah but um he
says that his whole love of medicine and
Anatomy and stuff like that which he did
seem to have stemmed from when he was a
child I don't know how old he was maybe
9 or 10 and he said that he was
terrified of skeletons now when he was a
kid he claims because he was smarter
than the other kids yeah
evidently that they picked on him
because they were jealous they were
haters yeah so it could be some truth to
that there could be some yeah right um
but like I said it's coming from him so
you know take that with a grain of salt
now he says that the kids used to pick
on him and stuff and that one day like
three uh older kids kind of tackled him
and dragged him into this doctor's
office and like showed him the skeleton
and he was talking about he was
terrified of the skeleton it looked like
it was gonna come out and get him and
all this other kind of stuff but he said
this particular incident was very
formative because he's like after I had
confronted that fear of death and the
skeleton and everything like that I
almost found that it like flipped around
and it became like a fascination right
yeah so then after that he I guess after
that he decided he want to go to medical
school and stuff like that now he I
think he left school at 16 and started
medical school and it obviously it
didn't take as long back then yeah I
like to add that I don't really buy his
story no I don't either I think he's
trying it's very convenient just very
convenient way of explaining you know
why he stole people's skeletons yeah
yeah she did do that yeah so he went to
medical school he actually started he
did some teaching and stuff like that he
actually married quite young his first
wife he had many at the same time and
her name was Clara Lovering and they had
a son actually named Robert and the
funny thing about the about Robert he
became a CPA later and many years later
he became when he was grown he became
the city manager of Orlando Florida
where we live Wow so HH Holmes
connection and a jgomes entering the
crustle sphere that's T it's all coming
together all come together not Russell
as the Nexus yeah okay so while he was
in medical school like I said he pet had
this you know fascination with skeletons
in anatomy and cadavers and he really
was into like dissection and all this
other kind of [ __ ] now medical school of
the time it's not like now where it's
like you know oh you're a doctor and
everything like that back then I think
doctors were kind of looked at a bit as
scans because in medical school you know
you needed cadavers to work on yeah you
don't you know you don't want some
they're cutting on you that's never cut
on a body before you know but there
weren't enough cadavers to go around now
so the medical students were kind of
great Robert courage yeah to kind of
bring in their own cadavers like you
know BYOC yeah they didn't like really
ask where if you showed up with a
cadaver for class no one's gonna ask
where that ship came from right so there
was a lot of grave robbing going on to
get cadavers and Holmes seemed to take
this he gotta use this to his advantage
because one thing he would do well okay
he had kind of two scams running and
this kind of happened this was from when
he was probably 18 19 20 years old he
started doing this kind of [ __ ] he would
either he would [ __ ] get cadavers and he
would like [ __ ] them all up yeah and
then he would he would use them for
insurance fraud yeah he claimed them
he'd open up an insurance policy on
somebody that he knew yeah and then make
that body look like look like that
person or mess them like burn their face
or something like that and then claim
that that person had died and then they
would they would split the money yeah
and then they would catch it on the [ __ ]
that was then that was a normal mo he
had a lot of those and it was called
scamming yeah they actually called that
scamming and this is where that word
camper yeah
now the thing is he had that and he also
had a side gig where and this kind of
came along later too even some of the
people that he allegedly killed you know
like I said they don't really know how
many but after he would kill them
sometimes in insurance scams then he
would get all the flesh off their bones
and he would sell the skeletons to
medical schools because they you know
they were in high demand so some of them
Lincoln you know 175 $200 there's a lot
of money back then this was you know
1890s
yeah probably talking about three grand
right then yeah it's good to let you
know I don't know I don't think you can
live on it but um you know it was a lot
of money so he had that kind of [ __ ]
going now the thing about it though is
that it seems that all of his kind of
insurance scams and stuff like that I'm
sure he probably made some money now and
then but from looking at like I was kind
of listening to um atom shelters talk
and everything listening I
don't know how much the insurance
companies fell for it right because the
thing about him is that when he was
younger he moved around a lot yeah he
used a [ __ ] ton of different aliases
different company names different you
know he changed his name a bunch of
times and he would move from city to
city and it does seem and and there are
actually a lot of lawsuits on record
where he would try to cash out a policy
you know with a cadaver or something
like that and the insurance company
would sue him right rather than pay out
so it doesn't appear that he was like
the best con man ever because it does
seem like that you know there was a lot
of competition he got caught a lot like
he wasn't jailed for it or anything cuz
usually he would take off and everything
like that but um so he would basically
just kind of skim off the top of his
successes and then just run from his
failures so he was you know he never
paid any fines but well some scams that
did work he did collect from that which
is weird because he probably could have
just made a better living had he just
played it straight you would think that
it's like once I don't know if there was
like some other problem that he couldn't
do another scam that he had going is
that he would sell this like special
medicinal tonic water we don't label on
it and everything and they came right
out of the city's tap yeah so you just
sell you a bottle of water they still do
that [ __ ] yeah they do they do that kind
of [ __ ] I don't know anything about it I
have to ask Russell crystal knows oh
yeah yeah and another thing another
thing too that he would do is that he
bought a lot of things on credit yeah
and there would be hay for them yeah he
did that a lot too so like I said con
man first and foremost but still a piece
of [ __ ] now his first wife evidently he
beat on her yeah she ended up they never
divorced but she ended up taking off mmm
so then he ended up marrying someone
else and I think her name was murder or
murder yeah murder Belknap but but
technically he was still married to
Clara his first wife now at one point he
ended up being married to at least three
women maybe four
yeah the last one I think was Minnie
Williams and they're not entirely sure
if they were married or not they acted
as though they were but um so he also a
bigamist because he never bothered
divorcing any of the other ones and he
had all these mistresses yet he had a
[ __ ] ton of mistresses see here's the
things that makes me question whether or
not this guy is an actual traditional
serial killer what makes me question is
that HHS is actually by all accounts
popular with women he wasn't he had no
problem he was evidently good-looking
they said he had kind of a slight bill
but but he came off as being kind of
stylish and elegant yeah very
intelligent very well very intelligent
well-spoken was super well-dressed and
he had no problem with women they were
falling all over him which that is not a
typical serial killer tonight
he seemed well he seemed more a Ted
Bundy type yes just in the way that he
seemed super charming sociopathic type
of Bundy was a canoes it was a confirmed
rapist though oh yeah and this guy
evidently was not not that I ever read
he never he never claimed to have raped
anybody and no one has ever claimed to
be and I really see I mean you know I
haven't read everything about it says HH
Holmes I have to say if you start like
Reese looking into the guy that's like a
huge [ __ ] rabbit hole right you can
go down into the [ __ ] all over the place
now the FBI is gonna say that what makes
a man a serial killers that the motive
is sexual yeah they are serial rapists
all right and this guy does not seem to
have had a sexual motive I don't think
so no it doesn't seem like which
technically by the FBI's standards the
FBI wouldn't probably not consider him
to be that type of a serial killer he's
multiple more like a mass murderer or a
mafia or multiple murder is probably the
distinction right now the first the
first inkling maybe that he was a killer
didn't really come about until around
1884 1885 and there were just rumors
that he had been seen with a little boy
and that little boy later disappeared
and stuff like that but I'm not real
sure how there was a lot of information
on that and that could have been his kid
because he did have a kid that was
around that age at the time somebody
been son and his son lived he didn't
kill his son and the weird thing too is
that I don't he didn't kill any of his
wives even though they think that he
probably killed well one of me locked
into a safe wasn't that a mistress I
believe it was yes yeah and he never
really said why at least far we haven't
read his confessions but the piece I've
read pieces that he doesn't give a
reason yeah did he ever give a reason
why he locked her in a safe and
suffocated I don't think he did I think
he just wanted her skeleton to say me
yeah it's weird how he had all that
stuff but he was so hard up for money
yeah he will have to pay for it he stole
most of it anyway yeah and the weird
thing too like I said he had a bunch of
wives he also had a couple kids like I
said Robert was the first son and then
with one of his other wives with with
murder who was his second wife he also
had a daughter named Lucy Ron and as far
as I know he didn't kill them then we
did this seem to have had a drug or a
gambling habit and even in those days
drugs were cheap you can get cocaine for
nothing yeah well it wasn't illegal it
wasn't illegal and it wasn't worth
anything so you didn't need money for
drugs whoa it's unclear what he needs
this money for because he wasn't using
it to pay the building per se maybe he
just wanted it he just wanted what where
did the money acts like a drought yeah
who knows but yeah so he ended up his
that his third wife was actually named
Georgiana yoke and he actually married
her in Colorado while he was still
married to the other two women now
probably the most famous [ __ ] about HH
Holmes started in about 1886 and this is
when he turned up in famously in Chicago
there's a lot of legends about this too
the legend says and there's even and
there's a documentary on Netflix called
HH Holmes America's first hero yeah we
saw and it's a good documentary like
it's creepy and spooky and everything
like that but they repeat a lot of the
stuff that's been debunked ok I guess to
kind of make it creepier and stuff like
that so yeah most of the documentaries
I've seen about HH Holmes are
entertaining but they are inaccurate its
legend yeah it's kind of like well Adam
Selzer he calls it a tall an american
tall tale it's like you know here's this
guy and he technically is a multiple
murderer he's a con man he's a horrible
person but then all these layers kind of
got added on
later on so the story goes that HH
Holmes arrived in Chicago and he started
working at a pharmacy that was owned by
Elizabeth Holton who I believe was duck
because they always say doctor Holton
than you assume it's a man but I think
the doctor was actually a woman okay and
the husband was so he worked in
construction or something like that but
they owned a pharmacy and he went to
work for them and the legend goes that
he killed them right like he was like
the the owner of the place was like an
old man and he had this much younger
wife which is which is also not the case
they were actually both about the same
age as him they were younger right and
he did work for them he did buy the
pharmacy right he didn't kill them no
they were alive and some yes and
actually I've seen pictures of their
graves if they lived a totally normal
life right he just said you know he
bought it off them and they just were
like no I never did he did he claims to
have killed them didn't he isn't that
where the story Casey I think that's
where the story came from
yes he was running around after his
arrest and claiming to have killed all
kinds of people much of the legend that
stemmed from it wasn't just newspapers
making [ __ ] up he made a lot of things
up yeah you know that were published in
papers and you know the newspapers might
have kind of finagled some of the [ __ ]
too but when he wrote some of his
confessions which were very
contradictory like sometimes he said I
didn't do anything so this death was an
accident blah-dee-blah but then like
after he got arrested and you know
convicted and everything like that he'd
said he pretty much killed and everybody
like you just like confessed to all
kinds of murders right so yeah I think
he did claim cuz he also claims that he
had killed one of his one of the other
students in medical school and sold his
skeleton but that dude was still alive -
yes fine kazooie right before they were
getting ready to hang him on the gallows
he recants everything I made it all up
yeah yeah which sister I think he made a
lot of that [ __ ] I think so like I said
the legend goes and even the the
documents on Netflix as good as it is as
entertaining as it is claims that he
killed the people whose pharmacy bought
and that is not the case they did not
die they lived a normal life it was fine
okay so we're at the halfway point now
so I will get into the whole
murder castle angle yeah this is my
favorite part yeah this is well this is
the most face like straights like
straight out of like Phantom of the
Opera
yeah like Edgar Allan Poe Phantom has a
lair with the whole torture facilities
Blair yeah yeah the fan of the Opera had
a dam in the book if you book is awesome
I almost thought it was a documentary
reading the book The Phantom had like
this octagonal room lined with mirrors
and in the middle of it a big like
razor-sharp crystalline look like a tree
that slowly rotated and he had central
heating that would pump heat into it and
and he would trap people in there and
they would start to hallucinate from the
heat thinking that they were dying in
the desert and they tried to climb a
tree but cut him all up it was weird man
that is pretty clean laro yeah he wrote
it yeah unfortunately now yeah the
ground layer on an island in the middle
of an underground lake that is pretty
cool that is pretty awesome yeah you
know like get it yeah let's get had a
tunnel that led to the theater that's a
pretty badass [ __ ] that is badass yeah
you had to get into a book row out yeah
to the island an underground island at a
keg party crossing the river six like
cross okay so we're gonna take a break
right now and we will come back and talk
about the murder castle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back now this is the
most famous part of the HH Holmes legend
yes the best part the murder castle yeah
okay so he buys a lot across from the
pharmacy where he was working and he
starts construction on credit of
initially what was a two-story building
now the first story was actually retail
space there was like a restaurant that
was a jewelry store there was a pharmacy
there was a couple of other things and
then the second floor was kind of
partitioned off into apartments it was
actually not intended as a hotel that is
that is a specious that is another
that's not true so actually he did have
like residents like living up in this
and some of these assets HH Holmes was
your was your landlord right wouldn't
that dam that be creepy and also the
third floor was actually not built until
later when he heard that the World's
Fair the Columbian Exposition was coming
to Chicago and he was intending to build
a third floor and turning it into a
hotel for all the tourists coming but
the third floor was never really
finished yeah now okay now here's the
funny thing when the hold on one second
what if you guys haven't seen this World
Fair that they had how'd that go for so
it was from May to October man that
thing was fantastic it really was that
look like something from the Roman
Empire yeah huge statues of like horses
and yeah it went all around a lake and
it just looked like well people came
city people came from all over the world
to see that yeah it's funny and it's
funny when it was over they just tore it
down yeah because it was evidently made
out of [ __ ] anyway it was just all
plaster yeah it looked awesome Dawson
yeah it's made with kind of treatment
yeah and they said it fell apart it
started to fall apart quickly so yeah
Jordan it was just meant to be temporary
man it was awesome and you know also
meant to be temporary like I said was
the third floor of Holmes's murder
castle okay here's a funny thing so hoes
wanted like a vault in his in his
building yeah so what he did was he
bought the vault on credit yeah they
came in and they put the vault in the
middle of the building and then he had
the building built around it yeah and
then he didn't pay so the people that
put the vault in there said we're gonna
repossess it
and he's like come get it [ __ ] yeah
there's this whole building around he's
like if you [ __ ] up my building I'll sue
you so they couldn't get it they
couldn't get this is back before that
credit score's yeah you can screw over
somebody and then screw over somebody
else and then somebody else there's no
way to know whether or not you can pet
you paid your bill or not right and it
pretty was that in the good old days
when you could get away with exactly you
could get away with this I'm moving to
the next donut changing your name yeah
but yeah so also in preparation for the
World's Fair he had this kind of the
third floor built kind of cheaply and he
bought like all this all this snazzy new
furniture and dishes and all this other
kind of stuff also on credit and what he
would do and I think this kind of
contributed something to the legend
later on about all these secret passages
and secret rooms and stuff like that
what he would do is all this furniture
when he heard that the creditors were
coming to take it back he had all these
little secret rooms like he would have a
room and then he would like wallpaper
over the door so you didn't know it was
there he would hide the furniture and
the [ __ ] that he bought in there so when
the creditors came he's like what
furniture I didn't buy furniture for me
repossess so they couldn't repossess it
as he said he didn't have it they didn't
find it so that was what some of the
secret passages were for was hiding
stuff that he had stolen so they
couldn't take it back later on the
legend grew about the murder castle that
it had let's let's see if we can catalog
like all the things that was supposed to
have it did have a vault that is true
they said that there was like a torture
chamber type of thing like in the
basement they said there was like a
crematorium in the basement they also
said that there was like a greased shoot
they would used to like do bodies down
the thing and you know various other
things like that like sealed rooms of
like little gas valves and that kind of
thing where he would like seal people in
rooms and like yeah I think most of that
is exaggerated there there actually was
a furnace in the basement he said that
he used it for glass bending because he
did actually try to start like a glass
bending business not only in that
building but
another one that he sort of owned and
will be laid down that's your last penny
what are they making bottles I guess so
yeah travels are just yeah that just
glassware in general I guess so I don't
know so there's really no evidence if
the one that's in the murder castle was
actually used to burn bodies I imagine
it might have been right you know like I
said he had other ones and he did have
kind of he did had kind of like
plausible deniability about this is what
I put it in there for um there wasn't
really a torture chamber not as such I
think there were some kind of things
that implied that he may have because I
do think that some of the people that he
killed that he probably sold their
skeletons right there was another guy
later that came out and said that he had
that he had purchased cadavers from HH
Holmes and that he's skeletonized that I
sold them to medical schools now just to
be clear where are your sources coming
from that this stuff was exaggerated
well like I said this is kind of all
over the place I'm sort of going from
like I said atom shelters newest book
where he kind of dug into a lot of the
old records that people hadn't really
seen for a while so he's kind of going
back into like legal records and he's
not saying that some of this stuff
didn't happen he's just saying that some
of it might have been exaggerated okay
because he's like he traced a lot of the
you know torture chamber type stories
and stuff about the murder castle he's
like that actually those stories came
along later okay
they were fictionalized accounts that
were put like in 40s pulp magazines and
things like that so a lot of the details
about that kind of stuff was from that
it wasn't actually from the time so
although when you go back to the time in
other words even the source material of
the period that stuff's not mentioned
some of it is but not that really okay
like the worst offender probably at the
time was a tabloid called the New York
world and they were kind of the first
ones to publish to publish a blueprint
of the murder castle that like labeled
the rooms is like is that the one they
asked chamber and all yeah that's shown
in that documentary yeah so like I said
some
that was like supposition now so it
wasn't based on any real blue blueprint
it was just something that they drew up
back at the office of what they thought
that there yeah some of it might have
had some truth behind it like ice this
is why it's like so hard to get to the
bottom of his case because there was so
much exaggeration in the press
there was exaggeration later on Rukn
fictionalized accounts he exaggerated
yeah he lied a lot of different rings
the one person that they are positive
that he killed hmm and this was the one
he was the only one he was convicted for
was Benjamin Petzl all right Benjamin
Petzl he met him he either came he was
like a carpenter so he either came to
work on his castle or they met each
other on another job sources kind of
differ on that but Benjamin Petzl was
kind of his right-hand man he was kind
of a big hulking kind of guy so he was
kind of like I don't know he was kind of
like his he was his muscle yeah right
yeah that kind of thing so Benjamin
Petzl probably knew about a lot of HH
Holmes insurance scams cuz he was
running those the whole time right so
one of the biggest ones that he was
gonna do and I don't think they
mentioned this in the documentary but
actually HH Holmes was actually going to
at first he was gonna fake his own death
and you know cash in on insurance that
way but when he tried to do that the
insurance company was like nah right you
know I mean so then he asks Benjamin
Petzl ok here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna fake your death
and then because Benjamin putzel had a
wife and he had five five kids they had
five kids you know he's like you will
you'll make all this money we'll put
your wife as the beneficiary and then
we'll all split it
so what enough oh I should mention too
that another insurance scam that he ran
he burned down the third floor of his
hotel at least twice okay and there are
records of and he had insurance policies
with several insurance companies
although about I think in one year I
think like nine of them sued him okay
other than payout so like I said he
wasn't great at this but yeah this guy's
not a mastermind he kept trying bigger
numbers yeah you know just do it in
numbers and it'll eventually it'll come
out okay so so he sets up this scheme
with Benjamin pencil now I'm not sure if
even from the beginning he planned on
really killing Benjamin Pytel right but
that's what happened right so I mean
these two had been like friends I guess
um for a while in his confessions he
said that he was done with him from yeah
yeah but he may have lied right may have
been by accident so what he did they
actually went to Philadelphia to pull
this off because it's where the
insurance company was based and they
installed
Benjamin Petzl in a department and he
actually lived there for a little while
under a pseudonym bf Perry and he's like
okay we're gonna find a cadaver that
looks like you or we're gonna make it
look like you died in an accident like
in a lab explosion right but when he
actually ended up doing was they don't
know if he poisoned him with chloroform
or made him drink chloroform or
something and then he set the body on
fire he wanted it to look like an
explosion right that he had died an
accident and at first that's how it was
ruled okay so and here's where it gets
creepy because okay so he really did
kill Benjamin Petzl but Benjamin pencils
wife still thought I mean she knew about
the scam right but she so she still
thought her husband was alive she
thought they faked it that it was some
cadaver
so HH Holmes says okay well I'm gonna go
identify the body but I need a family
member too so he takes one of the
daughters one of Benjamin pikeville's
daughter so I think was only 15 at the
time yeah he's like we're gonna go to
Philadelphia from Chicago and we're
gonna identify the body now evidently
like he identified the body obviously
cuz he killed him right um the daughter
I think they only let her look at the
teeth right so I'm not sure if she knew
that that was really her dad or not she
did say yeah that's my dad accessories
you're supposed to say right now at this
point for some reason Holmes decided
he's gonna take three of the Petzl
children and he takes him on this like
Odyssey like all it was like on trains
like he ever
[ __ ] contrary yeah they got confusing
for me for some reason he thought to
avoid suspicion that he had to separate
the children for a mother but it's never
really explained in any story I heard of
why he thought that it was suspicious
that the children were with the money I
don't know if he was just kind of got
off on him telling her it's good because
she he kept telling we're gonna go you
know we're gonna go meet up with
Benjamin right and then they would get
to one city oh he's not here we must
have just missed him now we have to go
to this city for us so it and he was
keeping them separate so he kept like
three of the kids and then the the wife
and the baby because they had one that
was like only one or something like that
and he would like sometimes they'd be in
the same town or even I think a couple
times they were even on the same train
yeah without knowing without about each
other yeah and the weird thing too is
that in some of the cities like his
third wife Georgiana yoke sometimes she
would be in the city too and she had no
[ __ ] idea what was going on yeah
evidently trying to keep everybody in
this family pretty much separate two
different groups yes so you can
manipulate him they're all trying to
write letters to one another but he's in
intercepting letters yeah he didn't
think that gorging letters to I think I
don't remember but it's just like I said
his story is like so complex and it's
like why did he do all this [ __ ] I don't
know but the thing is okay what
eventually ended up happening even
though they did get the PAMP from the
insurance company he obviously took most
of the money I think he only gave like
300 bucks to the wife
but somebody started to be somebody at
the insurance company or somebody in
around there started to become
suspicious that maybe that wasn't an
accident all right so the Pinkertons the
very famous Detective Agency were hired
to look into it and they determined yeah
he probably killed that dude so then
they start looking for him and once they
suspected that and at this point three
of the pypes old Rijn no one knew where
they were right so then they kind of
started following his trail backtracking
stuff like that now he did get arrested
at one point oh it and actually this is
how he ended up getting caught he got
arrested for insurance fraud he got put
in jail with another dude yeah they
Marion Hedgepeth who was kind of a big
like a Crim
at the time now he told Marion Hedgepeth
let's do let's do this insurance scam
and I'll give you 500 bucks right if you
tell me the name of a lawyer that will
work all this out like a crooked lawyer
right so Marion Hedgepeth did that after
HH Holmes got out and you know they did
the scam and everything like that he
neglected to send $500 and Marion
Hedgepeth so when Marion Hedgepeth read
about all this [ __ ] going on he narked
yeah random-ass says I got you sucker
yeah so that is as essentially so always
pay your criminal yeah you know sniff
your partner's yeah exactly sniff your
partners in crime that's what happens
you end up getting caught so that's kind
of how the Pinkertons got onto him and
everything like that cuz I forgot to
mention
so they chased him around and stuff like
that and this other investigator gets on
I think his name was Frank Geyer and he
starts fought he starts retracing
Holmes's circuitous journey like around
the country with these kids now in a
property that Holmes owned in Toronto
they found the bodies of the two little
girls yeah and also at another property
he owned I can't remember what city it
was they also found what were probably
the remains of the little boy yeah it
looked like he had burned them like in
the stove like tried to burn it up there
were like little bones and stuff like
that so for sure Benjamin pine-sol he
killed and for sure he killed those
three kids right those are the ones that
are positive he basically killed that
woman's entire family yeah they didn't
kill her did he did the baby got away
though yeah and he didn't kill the baby
yeah but um and actually I think one
other kids know cuz I think she had two
of the kids whether the youngest one in
them here's the weirdest thing if you if
you really kind of look at that look at
the big picture of this case home spends
most of his time riding around on trains
yeah from city to city trying to escape
things doing lots of paperwork and
trying to figure out all these scams I
mean it's a lot of work ok boy work like
huh yeah literally track of all that
[ __ ] he doesn't want to work as a doctor
so he's one of he wants to work as a con
man and it's almost like it would be
easier just to work as a damn doctor you
would think that's what kills me I get
it
he had all these aliases he had all
these scams running at the same time he
had three wives he had like that
how do you keep track of all of that
stuff how do you keep track of all your
aliases I can barely remember my own
name half that time how do you keep
track of like ten other ones that like
there's all these lawsuits going on also
it's just crazy
yeah he's a crazy crazy person yeah it's
a lot of work to avoid work it's like
it's not worth it yeah but yes okay for
sure he killed those four now they think
probably very very likely he also killed
five other people which were either like
all his mistresses many Williams and her
sister nanny Williams he probably killed
both of them many Williams I don't know
if he actually legally was married
turned there is no legal marriage
certificate on file but like there are
with the other three the three that he
legally married he didn't kill them they
learnt they're fine but the ones that
were just mistresses because sometimes
he would hire you know women to work in
his you know work in his pharmacy or
whatever so officially there's
officially how many did he kill probably
nine probably not now when he was
finally arrested yeah he actually
confessed he ended up confessing to 27
right however some of those people were
still alive proof that the dude lied his
ass on right now some of those people he
did kill like I said there were five of
the women not out of the nine that we
pretty much know for sure how many of
those nine had a sexual motive I don't
think any none of them like I think the
motive was always scamming some right or
something like that or someone just got
in his way because it seems like okay
some so nanny and many why who I think
we're sisters he killed them because
they had a $40,000 property in Fort
Worth Texas and he wanted it right so I
think he probably just killed them
because of that because you know really
at the property some of the other
mistresses he might have killed them
either because he got sick of the murder
her husband's got the way or they got
pregnant because some of them he said
that he had tried to give them an
abortion and they died that way I don't
know how true that is he did admit that
in a couple of cases yeah he wanted
mistress
but he wanted mistresses and wives but
he didn't want children not for them
yeah you know where the guy is not so
much like a traditional modern serial
killer then what you're dealing with
yeah it kind of like an 1800s for serial
poisoner whatever yeah isn't in people
to steal money because he doesn't really
seem to have gotten any particular like
a sexual satisfaction like he didn't get
off on killing people he just seemed to
kill them because they were in the way
they were obstructing something he
wanted to do and he was a little bitty
guy so probably not really capable of a
whole lot of physical violence and there
doesn't seem to be any torture involved
not this said that was a medieval rack
see I see I don't think that was really
there I think that was a later
exaggeration added like I said I think
that he was very he was a very practical
killer okay if he didn't have to kill
you he wouldn't all right but if he had
to he would and he wasn't really
particularly bothered and the whole
murder castle thing probably not true
yeah I mean I'm not saying he did kill
people in and they did find like some
rooms like I think they found they found
one woman named Julia Smyth or Julia
Connor she's known as both things cuz
one was her married name and one was her
maiden name and she had a daughter named
pearl and both of them disappeared right
and they did find some bone fragments
like in the basement of it so they do
think he might have killed a few people
there like I said including some of his
mistresses but they didn't find bodies
okay now some of the bodies they think
like I think Emma Lyons two grand who
was another one of his mistresses that
he probably killed you know he kind of
said oh well I sold her skeleton to a
medical school but there was like no way
to check that back then so maybe he did
maybe he didn't he probably did kill her
though cuz she did this if so when I
first found this case I was a kid and a
friend of mine had these damn serial
killer baseball cards and you know and
he was I remember those things yeah and
on the back of it had a picture of that
murder castle and it said you know he
built this huge labyrinth the four story
story labyrinth that had racks and oiled
shoots and secret yeah
ways and the basement had a huge pit
filled with lie and Bob right but that's
not actually that's a
mischaracterization of that that for at
least an exaggeration okay at least an
exaggerated all right like I said I'm
not saying he wasn't a killer he was
right he probably just that it was not
this purpose-built labyrinth right you
could chase people through a maze and
yeah yeah he didn't build it
specifically for that okay like some
kind of like Torquemada kind of right
you know I'm gonna build a [ __ ] a
torture chamber he didn't build it for
that no basically newspapers came up
with that idea and then like I said in
the 40s when they started writing like
all these true crime pulp fiction kind
of books they took that story kind of
ran with it so when the murder castle
hit a scam castle yeah
that murders would happen in it murders
would happen in every now and then if
necessary okay now after he was caught
like I said he confessed at 27
altogether okay like according to if you
go to Adam Seltzer's blog which is a
mysterious Chicago calm and I would
recommend it because it's fascinating
there's other stuff besides HH Holmes
but he's written a lot about HH Holmes
on there to his updated victims list he
has them separated into like certain
likely maybe and no so he's got four in
the definite which is Benjamin Pines
alone the three pile children all right
five in the very likely which are the
five mistresses then he's got 28 that
are possibilities and these are names
that Holmes brought up in his
confessions and stuff like that that
either did vanish around that time or
you know their whereabouts were unknown
so it's possible he could have killed
them now he also came up with 22 victims
that Holmes confessed to killing but
we're not dead right so that kind of
goes against his credibility once you
start throwing it that this guy is a
confession machine
my very favorite one of these and he and
Adam Selzer mentioned it in one of his
talks was this woman named Kate Durkee
and she actually kind of did get scammed
by him like it was some kind of
insurance game that he pulled off or
whatever and he claimed later that he
had killed her and I loved that she kind
of marched into this like newspaper
office or opposed
something like that and she made this
statement she says I have not been
murdered either by HHS or anyone else
I've never been murdered she said I've
never been murdered by HH Holmes or
anyone else which I thought was very
yeah she's like I'm right here
[ __ ] yeah but like some of the
people that he claimed he had you know
that he had killed like I said the guy
that he went to medical school with
anybody killed and stuff like that we're
actually still alive and lived like a no
so so a body count probably more like
around 2530 I'm saying 9 for sure yeah
27 could be right it's that's not crazy
because some of the people that were in
the maybe things like I said did kind of
vanish around that time and but they
don't know where they were after his
lies and the technology at the time
try crime more like 20 yeah which is bad
and all that's bad enough but like it's
not 200 No
right yeah there's no way right he did
not kill 20 and even like I said even on
some of the documentaries they'll kind
of repeat the myth that like oh there
are 50 people that came to Chicago for
the World's Fair that were unaccounted
for they're missing or so like that that
is also an exaggeration yeah so here's
the thing when he first got arrested he
was kind of like deny deny deny deny but
they were kind of like well and when he
went on trial for killing Benjamin Petzl
he fired his lawyers like the first day
I was like I got this [ __ ] yes like I
said very self-aggrandizing very
arrogant very cocky he was he acted his
own lawyer for I think about a day and a
half until he started to lose and then
maybe I should hand this over to people
that actually know what they're doing
but he's still lost anyway so he did get
convicted for for only the killing of
Benjamin Python he was sentenced to hang
now once he was sentenced to hang and he
knew that he was going to die and you
know they gave him an execution date
I guess he decided to make a total 180
and just say yeah I did [ __ ]
everything because William Randolph
Hearst
yeah they offered him money offered him
a [ __ ] ton of money it actually about
$200,000 $250,000 in today's money um
for a full confession so he evidently
wrote this big huge long confession
Randy
Scottie do it yeah he wanted to know I
guess yeah maybe he was a serial killer
junkie himself maybe he was a fan
well serial killers sold papers yeah
it's basically what it boy
so I forgot now whether now there's also
some controversy over whether what
Holmes wrote in his thing if that's what
he actually wrote worth and newspapers
add in some fun details yeah there's no
way of knowing all right regional draft
I mean they do but it's like it could be
I don't know it could be the original
draft in his handwriting well that I
don't know so but yeah and and you know
so like I said it's kind of one of those
things where you can't really get to the
bottom of the mystery it's like a lot of
the [ __ ] is gone or you know a lot of
the [ __ ] was made but you know if you
say in this that's just fried [ __ ]
that's just Brian a private it might be
yeah but in this particular confession
he kind of some of the stuff was maybe
true like when he talked about killing
the two pipes or girls he said you know
I put them in a trunk and then I you
know drilled a hole in the top of the
trunk and then put gas in the truck he
probably did do that because they defied
him the how did he get him in the trunk
he trick them into the trunk probably
yeah or it married rukmini he did he
drugged them he didn't say because he
was kind of a big advocate of like
drugging people like he was super into
like drugging people the chloroform and
all that stuff so like I said he doesn't
seem to have gotten any sort of charge
out of it right in terms of torture
although I have to say that I think the
two little girls he he found he they
they found them buried like under this
house yeah they were nude I don't think
they found any clothes with him huh so I
don't know if he took the clothes off
after they were dead just to like
Fernandez what he claimed yeah I think
he took the clothes off after like so I
don't know if he really got any sexual
charge they were just in the way or any
thought well I'll just get rid of him
right he just didn't really seem to have
like people seemed just like objects to
him like you were just in the way so I
good enough yeah you're just in the way
of me getting this money I do you know
he didn't really enjoy killing I don't
think he would just do it if I enjoyed
the power of being a god-like force who
could select who would die in this and
that but
necessarily like the you know he wasn't
getting into like the suffering or
anything like that or yes drawing out
your drawing out the death right torture
oh no ya seem to be doing that so he
published his big long confession which
was which in which he lovingly recreated
a bunch of his murders and stuff but a
lot of it was [ __ ] cuz some of the
people were still alive so they did
actually hang him for the murder of
Benjamin Petzl like you said when he was
on the gallows with the noose around his
neck he's like I take it all back you
know yeah I did it all up but then they
were like [ __ ] and they pulled the lever
anyway so there was one case I forgot
who it was they put the noose around his
neck and as they're pulling that as
they're getting ready to pull the switch
they you know to have him fall down
there and snap his neck he goes on his
way down he goes I'm Jack the Ripper
that was actually we did a show about
that yes is that Thomas Neil Kramer is
that that other dude I forgot no he
didn't say he he said they thought he
said I am Jack that yeah I think that's
the only reason people think that he's
Jack the Ripper and that's actually a
good segue because now he just didn't
wanna but he just wanted him to do it
post public execution so he can stop the
run off but yeah but yeah funny you
mentioned you're gonna laugh and we're
laughing at dudes grasping for straws at
the end of their life because we [ __ ]
bags up yeah it's not like it's not like
it was like it's a real person yeah yeah
well it's not like it was an innocent
person here like oh man that sucks you
know the yeah these are pieces of [ __ ]
but so yeah if I don't you should
mention Jack the Ripper because one of
the latest things that it might have
only been a book that came out this year
or last year
Geoff Mudgett who is actually the great
grandson of HH Holmes because you know
Herman Mudgett was his real name he has
come out as stating that he thinks that
HH Holmes and Jack the Ripper were the
same person
ah no I'm likely yeah now okay now I
should note I think like I said I
haven't read his book it seems to me
that the only reason that he thinks that
is one because some of the police
sketches of Jack the Ripper that were
made at the
because what Islam looked like the mo a
totally different right look like and
also he said Oh their handwriting was
the same but okay I should say this
though one there were a lot of dudes
with those big-ass mustaches no kind of
hats and stuff that was just the style
back then so a lot of dudes look like
that to the firm how letters from Jack
they don't know if that's actually the
killer I mean that one was probably foam
because it had the kidney and stuff if
that was a human if that was a human
kidney they had no way of knowing that
back I got that from the butcher shop
right might have been a B for us so am i
don't think there's an ax in C and
here's the thing and Jeff budget too he
says oh well there's all this time like
when the Jack the Ripper murders were
happening in 1888 that HH Holmes
movements in the US were unaccounted for
and he said that he was in London around
that time but here's the problem now
according to Adam Selzer is the guy that
wrote the most recent book he has found
some papers from that time when the Jack
the Ripper killings were going on he's
like I found a voter registration in
Chicago where HH Holmes registered to
vote now he's like now I should say that
he cared about democracy his signature
was not on it it was just like a clerk
signature he's like so yeah technically
he didn't have side but he's like why
would somebody be registering him to
vote if he wasn't there he registered it
had something to do with proving that he
lived there so he could do some kind of
scam later yeah that's what I mean so he
found some other papers from that time
that showed that that Holmes was
probably in the city doing business at
that time when the murders were going on
and like I said also totally different
modus operandi totally different Jack
the Ripper picked off random women and
got off on cutting them up yeah and they
were hags
they were yeah oh yeah these prostitutes
right he was just pick them at random
off the street if it was easy women like
that would have been far beneath HH
holmes HH holmes may have these women in
his the women that he married and the
women that he dated you know as what he
called mistresses
yeah they were evidently all
good-looking young and the ones that
have pictures are more yeah we're very
were pretty yeah yeah when he you know
he cream of the crop
yes episode
desired guy oh yeah he had no problem
problem like I said and a lot of women
that came to work for him even if they
were married he would he would do
something yeah so you know so he was
evidently very tuned as a player yeah oh
yeah but like I said he did not pick
random people he did not seem to get any
satisfaction from killing people he
would pick people he would kill people
that had something that he wanted and
the person being alive was in his way of
getting what he wanted that's it it was
a completely practical motive he did not
take any of their guts as trophies or
anything like Jack there were pretty
much totally totally different so it was
almost kind of more like a vampire yeah
you know got rid of you to just take
your [ __ ] - just take your [ __ ] yeah
that's pretty much all he did and like I
walked around like he was a nobleman
yeah really just a conman who would kill
if he had to right but you know so I
don't I really don't think and I know
it's very it sells books like to say
this person was Jack the Ripper that
person was Jack the Ripper you know look
how [ __ ] Patricia Cornwell she got
like she sold like 50 s quintillion
books saying that the artist Walter
Sickert
was Jack the Ripper which probably he
wasn't I think the only evidence she had
was oh he did some paintings that looked
like Jack the Ripper's crime scenes I'm
like yeah it was a fascinating case it
was like all over the papers it's like
why wouldn't an artist be inspired by
that I mean that seems really dumb it's
like you know that's that's kind of like
saying just because I write horror
stories I really do that [ __ ] right
that's [ __ ] so anyway he could
probably wrap this up I think yeah we're
probably good okay so uh like I said the
case of HH holmes is so vast and there's
like so much so much research on it
stuff like that and you know sure I got
a lot of [ __ ] wrong yeah you're gonna
have serial killer fanboys jump
announces but you didn't read this you
didn't read it because they all do that
oh I'm telling him that I'm telling you
right now which ones I read I read devil
in the White City which which is partly
fictionalized and Eric Larsen has said
that now they're actually making a movie
out of that and in from and the purpose
of this show is to introduce the cases
to our audience
let them research it you know this is
not source material and like I said I
also rent appraise by her
very famous book about Enric and we and
we watched several documentaries that I
watched the one on Netflix there was one
on the biography channel I think I watch
that one you know and I read most of
Adam Seltzer's posts on his blogs about
interesting case even back in the day
what I heard it though it just smelled
fishy and what you found actually kind
of confirms some my suspicions I mean
like I said the case wasn't as
extravagant yes he sucked as a person
but was he like a modern Bluebeard who
built this building specifically for the
purpose of just but no I don't think so
he built it for other reasons and killed
some people in there and whatever but I
don't think he built it exactly for that
he was just a scammer yeah that's what
he was yeah it sounds right yeah so
that'll do it for this episode since
we've already got a little bit over okay
and so if you like these true-crime
episodes and be sure to check out my new
book the faceless villain if you haven't
already it's out in print and ebook and
will be at an audiobook eventually when
I get time to work on it and also if you
would like to support the show then go
to our patreon at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast and do a monthly
donation or if you would like to just do
a one-time donation then you can go to
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast on
wordpress.com and there's a little link
on the sidebar and also check out our
latest movie review which was the road
warrior and also kind of fury road cuz
you know we get we always get excited
we're talking about Mad Max stuff and we
have to kind of talk about fury road so
it was kind of a 2/4 review like all in
one so check that out if you haven't yet
and that'll do it for this episode of
zode 64 see you next Tuesday bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you